What is causing climate change?
I mean, it’s greenhouse gas emissions
from human activities, of course.
But which human activities?
Who specifically is burning
all of these fossil fuels,
and for what and where?
It sounded strange when I first heard it,
but I have come to learn
that even today in the 21st century,
scientists have surprisingly
little information about this question.
So I'm part of a new coalition
of scientists, activists,
and actually tech companies
working to address this issue.
It's been a stranger journey
than I expected.
Let me break it down for you.
So we've known for decades that emissions
are rising in the atmosphere
because we can see them
swirling up around there.
So the famous Keeling Curve is based
on what we can actually see from space.
But what you can't easily see from space
is how did they get there?
It still boggles my mind,
but even in the year 2021,
in most countries and most
sectors of the economy,
our process for actually answering
where are all those emissions coming from
is still to ask polluters
how much they polluted.
Just kind of like hope
nothing is missing in that inventory
and then add up all those numbers,
sometimes manually, on paper.
It's amazing that every
single country in the world
has agreed to this process.
It's one of the great things
that brings me hope
that everyone in the world is essentially
contributing to this process.
But it is such a stopgap solution.
If we're really serious
about stopping climate change,
you can only manage what you can measure,
and we need to have more information.
We need to have information,
not like letting it take years
to compile manual reports.
I mean, there are countries
that haven't had an emissions
inventory in 20 years.
What are you actually supposed to do
with information that old?
We need to not just be looking
at what are the emissions
of entire countries,
because if you want to know
how to reduce them,
you need to know:
Do I need to go
after cars or factories?
What in my country is driving
all these emissions?
We can't keep relying on asking polluters
to report how much they polluted.
And there's even more subtle problems.
Like, one that really gets me
is if one company reports
it's reduced its emissions,
we don't have a good way to know right now
is that a real reduction,
should we celebrate,
or did they just play hot potato
and sell something that pollutes
to another company?
If we want to get really serious
about fighting climate change,
we need better tools.
We need to have some way
to get information
in ideally real-time, not years later;
that doesn’t rely
on just asking the polluters;
that has really detailed information
about where those emissions came from,
not just country level;
that is open and transparent,
so everybody knows they can trust it;
and ideally, that’s free,
because we can't just have a situation
where only those who can afford to pay
know how much is being emitted.
So that's a serious scientific
and engineering challenge.
How exactly would you go about
building a system like that?
Well, you might want to start
with a photo like this.
We know, because this is one
of the few power plants in the world
that actually has a CO2
emissions sensor in its stack
that at the time this photo was taken,
it was emitting 2,930 tons
of CO2 per hour.
But we also know that a short time later,
the same exact power plant
looked like this.
And at that time, of course,
it was emitting zero tons of CO2.
I mean, you can see that
with the unaided human eye.
But often, it's a little more complicated.
And so we have started to work
as a cluster of small NGOs
on training computer vision AI algorithms
to look at hundreds of thousands
of photos like this
to recognize what a power plant
looks like when it's polluting
a certain amount of pollution from space.
The reason we can do this
is that there are so many free
and public satellite images available now
from sources like NASA's Landsat 8
or China's Gaofen 6.
It's possible actually to get
photos every few days
of every major power plant
in the entire world.
And so my organization, WattTime,
and a number of other small NGOs
have teamed up to build
an artificial intelligence algorithm
that can scan visual imagery
like this every few days
and look, without asking the polluters,
to see how much they are polluting
for every power plant in the world.
It's pretty exciting.
(Applause)
You can actually do better than that.
Because there are other forms
of satellites as well.
Just like in the movies,
we can switch to thermal infrared
and we can look at whether
power plants are hot as well.
That matters because that's a completely
independent assessment
with different satellites
and different techniques.
So if those two methods agree,
that's really encouraging.
We found the right answer.
You can also look at information like:
Downwind from a power plant
a little while later,
do we see more emissions
in the atmosphere where they ought to be?
You can even do really subtle things,
like you can look at the cooling water
intake valve near a power plant.
Using commercial imagery from Planet,
we are able to see ripples
in a river near a power plant.
And that means it's
drawing in so much water
because it's that hot and polluting.
So no one of these techniques is perfect,
but it's pretty remarkable
how accurate they start to get
when you combine many,
many different independent techniques.
We got pretty excited
when we were starting to get
pretty good results
measuring all the power
plants in the world.
But then Al Gore, amazing as he is,
encouraged us to dream bigger.
And so we got the challenge from him
and the partners of Generation
to not just think small in terms
of power plant emissions,
but to see if we could do
all human emissions
from all major sources in the planet
and make that available
and free to everyone.
And with their support
and with a whole lot of teaming up
with other organizations,
collectively, all of us
have been able to do just that.
So --
(Applause)
A really exciting example of this
is Transition Zero.
So they're a UK-based organization
that is able to monitor
the emissions of steel mills,
and they can do that even when those
emissions are invisible to the naked eye.
Because one of the really important,
interesting things
about artificial intelligence
is with different forms
of signals from satellites,
we can look at very specific
chemical processes
in different parts of the supply chain.
You also have the ability
to measure factory farms.
Did you know even the United States EPA
in charge of regulating them
does not have a complete inventory
of how many highly polluting
factory farms are in the United States?
But a start-up named Synthetic
has been able to apply computer vision
to build an inventory of them
and is now scaling it up to expose
every factory farm worldwide.
RMI is monitoring oil and gas emissions
from production and refining.
Blue Sky Analytics, based in India,
is monitoring crop fires and forest fires.
You want to talk about car transportation?
Johns Hopkins University is modeling
all the ground transportation
and looking at the road
networks worldwide.
Each one of our organizations
has learned to specialize
in one or two forms
of particular emissions.
But we’re sharing them all in a giant
database known as Climate TRACE.
One of the interesting things
about Climate TRACE
is that it's fundamentally built
on global techniques.
So here you're looking from Ocean Mine's
model of every single ship on the planet
and the associated emissions.
This is really powerful
because it used to be the case
that only rich countries
can afford to look at their emissions
in great detail.
We are talking about properly
global systems
that are available and free for everyone.
The reason, of course, we can do this
is because satellites
have come down so much in cost.
There are now literally thousands of eyes
in the sky up above us,
and many of them are actually free
and open to anyone
to use that information.
But you know what's come down in recent
years even more in cost than satellites?
Big data and AI.
I mean, we now live in a world
where if a certain meme
is trending on Twitter,
there are automated marketing algorithms
that know that worldwide in minutes.
We suspect there are stock market
algorithms that know it in seconds;
it’s really useful for day traders.
So we actually exist as a society
spending more resources on monitoring
funny cat video views on the internet
than a civilization-threatening crisis.
(Laughter)
Something just seems strange about that.
And so at Climate TRACE,
we decided to take a tiny,
tiny fraction of those resources
and those technical
monitoring capabilities
and reallocate them
to actually monitoring emissions.
So it's this giant shared database.
I mean, we have software engineers
volunteering their time
on nights and weekends
to make the data engineering work.
We have academics validating algorithms.
We have NGOs running different models.
We have sensor and satellite
data companies donating code.
And much like Wikipedia,
what's going on is all of these many,
many different experts
are sharing our resources
in a single common pot
that anyone can see,
everything has to be cross-validated,
and it’s available to the public.
The biggest difference from Wikipedia
is there's a lot more
real-time sensors involved.
So why are we doing this?
In a word, transparency.
We were approached early in the project
by a former climate negotiator
who told us that the heart
of the Paris Agreement
is supposed to be
that countries are able to see
what everybody else is doing.
They can learn to trust each other,
and that's why they're willing
to hold hands and leap together.
But the problem is, there's a lot
of self-reporting going on,
and a lot of countries
don't have the resources
to do this very expensive
old form of monitoring.
And so what we’ve tried to prioritize
for Climate TRACE version one
is releasing before COP26,
last month, September 21,
a version of Climate TRACE that is free
and available to everybody,
that has the emissions for every country,
every sector and every year on the planet.
So here we're looking, for example,
at the emissions of rice production
in Malaysia in 2020.
Or Australia's electricity emissions
in the same year.
This is all available to anyone
on climatetrace.org for free.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Now it is imperfect.
Artificial intelligence starts out
not quite as good,
and it gets better over time.
So far, one of the things
we’ve been able to measure is:
What does this compare to
what countries have been reporting?
So we can't say that our methods
are completely perfect yet,
but one of the big questions we get is:
Should countries trust each other?
And one of the most surprising things
I think I've learned from this project
is that I think the answer is yes.
I mean, we've definitely found
some missing emissions.
There's a few industries that we need
to go have some hard conversations with.
But by and large,
what we've been really struck by
is the vast majority of countries
appear to have been able
to get away with murder,
but negotiating with each other
in complete good faith.
If you're a climate negotiator
heading to COP26,
I would like to just pause
and appreciate what that implies for trust
in what's about to happen.
But I think it'd be a waste of AI
if we stopped there.
So our next step
for Climate TRACE version two,
what we're working on,
is making every single emitting asset
in the world visible.
So it's going to look like this.
And what that's going to mean is not just
national totals, but giving tools.
I’ve spoken with governments
that are interested in knowing:
Where in our economies
are the emissions coming from?
I've spoken with companies
who'd like to green their supply chains,
but they have to know which factories
are cleaner than which other factories.
I've spoken with asset managers
who are investing 43
trillion dollars in net-zero,
but to actually achieve their goals,
they need a way to manage and measure:
Are those emissions reductions
really happening?
So I think it's pretty exciting
that we can now ensure
that if anybody in the world
is trying to hide emissions,
they can just forget about it.
Those days are over.
(Applause)
Thank you.
But the part that really
excites me the most
is giving tools to others
in the climate fight
to get the job done faster.
Thank you.
(Applause)